[موسيقى]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله قضت المحكمه
المصريه للامور المستعجله بحظر انشطه
تنظيم الاخوان المسلمين والجماعه المنبثقه
عن وجمعيته الم شهر في مارس الماضي واي
مؤسسه متفرعه منها او تابعه اليها او
منشاه باموالها او تتلقى منها الدعم نتوقف
مع هذا الخبر لنناقشه في محورين
ما دلالات توقيت صدور هذا القرار وهل يمثل
اعلانا بانتهاء محاولات المصالحه الوطنيه
في النصر
وما تداعيات القرار على التيار الاسلامي
والاخوان المسلمين في ضوء خبرتهم
التاريخيه في العمل في ظل تقييد القانوني
والامني
وجهت جماعه الاخوان المسلمين في مصر من
قبل قرارين بالحل في عام ثمانيه واربعين
واربعه وخمسين من القرن الماضي لكن القرار
الجديد ان ياتي بعد ابعادها عن قمه السلطه
بانقلاب عسكري وقد وصفت الجماعه حكم محكمه
الامور المستعجله بحظر تنظيمها بانه سياسي
واكدت استمرار وجودها على الارض واعتبر
قانونيون ايضا ان الحكم سياسي ومصيره
الغاء فيما رحبت به قوى سياسيه مصريه من
بينها حزب التجمع اليساري الذي حرك دعوى
حظر انشطه تنظيم الاخوان
كان قرار المتوقعه لكن المفاجئ فيه كونه
جاء شاملا لكل ما له صله بهم جماعه وافراد
جمعيه وتنظيمها بحظر انشطه تنظيم الاخوان
المسلمين
لجمهوريه مصر العربيه
وجماعه الاخوان المسلمين المنبثقه عن هذا
التنظيم
وكما الاخوان المسلمين
ليس هذا فقط بل ان القرار صدر عن محكمه
مخوله بالامور المستعجله بينما ينظر
القضاء في دعوه وقف قيد جمعيه الاخوان في
نوفمبر وفي دعوه اخرى بحل تنظيم الجماعه
في ديسمبر المقبل اما المفارقه تتمثل ب
مصارعه محكمه تنظر في امور مستعجله بحذر
جماعه عمرها اكثر من ثمانيه عقود يشمل
قرار المحكمه هي الجماعه وكل ما انبثق
عنها واي منشاه تتلقى منها اموالا ودعما
ما يعني بحسب معارضين عقابا جماعيا قد
يشمل نقابات وجمعيات ومؤسسات مجتمع مدني
يتولى ادارتها او يشارك فيها عناصر من
الاخوان سواء بصفتهم الفرديه او الحزبيه
ويقول هؤلاء ان القرار قد يشمل اذا ساءت
السلطات تاويله مصادره اموال في البنوك
وشركات في القطاع الخاص يمتلكها او يشارك
في ملكيتها عناصر من الجماعه بصفتهم
الفرديه ياتي هذا في ظل ما يصفه انصار
الاخوان بحمله كراهيه غير مسبوقه فالحزب
الذي رفع الدعوه على الجماعه يساريه
ومعلوم ان اليسار والجماعه ساند بدرجه او
باخرى ثوره يوليو الا انهما سرعان ما تعرض
للعشر والقمع في حقبه عبد الناصر على ان
الجماعه التي ظلت محظوره كانت تحتفظ ب
هامش حركه يتسع او يضيق من الاضطهاد في
عهد عبد الناصر الى المشاركه من تحت
الطاوله في عهد السادات وصولا الى
المشاركه على من ضمن الحاكم في عهد مبارك
اقسم بالله العظيم قبل انتخاب مرسي رئيسا
كانت الجماعه ممثله وبقوه في البرلمان ما
يعني بحسب مناصر الاخوان ان الجماعه تكتسب
شرعيتها من وجودها في الحياه السياسيه
سواء كانت محظوره ام لا اما حضرها يشكك في
جدوى المصالحه الوطنيه التي ينادي بها من
في السلطه بل قد ينسف مستقبل الحوار معها
اذ ان اعضاءها حسب القرار اصبحوا خارجين
على القانون يلاحقون وهم والحال هذه لا
يحاورون
موضوع حلقتنا نناقشه مع ضيفينا هنا في
الاستوديو المحامي منتصر زيات رئيس اللجنه
القوميه للدفاع عن سجناء الراي
والدكتور عمر هاشم ربيع الخبير في مركز
الاهرام للدراسات السياسيه والاستراتيجيه
مرحبا من ضيفينا الكريمين
الزيجات من الناحيه القانونيه تقييم كل
هذا الحكم بسم الله الرحمان الرحيم حكم من
عدم اللي انه صدر
اخطا فى تطبيق القانون
هذه المحكمه غير مختصه صدر من محكمه غير
مختصه اه انا افهم انه لما نكون يعني شركه
مصلحه
نريد ان نفرض الحراسه شيء من هذه الاشياء
الحقيقه المستقله خلاف الخوف من اه يعني
ضياع المال عادت التحفظ مثلا في هذه الاطر
في هذا الاطار يفهم ان يلجا الى محكمه
الامور المسيح لو كانت الدعوه التحفظ على
الاموال اذا كان البعض يردد انه احنا مش
عارفين فلوس الاخوه فيه منين بتروح فين
كان يمكن فهم اه قامت الدعوه باعتبارها
جرائم تحفظها على اموال الجماعه او جمعيه
الاخوان المسلمين انما جماعه بهذا الحجم
بهذا التاريخ
خمسه وثمانين او يزيد ينظر في امرها محكمه
جزئيه قاضي واحد اوقات اه يعني هذا الشيء
هذا فيه وانا استطيع ان اقول ان هذا الحكم
لا يساوي المداد الذي كتب هل كان هذا الع
بهذا العدد هذه العبثيه كانت مقصوده
لاهداف سياسيه ربما هو الحكم السياسي اذا
جاز ان انصف الحكم كما وصفه البعض القانون
بالسياسه انا وصفت انه سياسي بانه في ما
نشر من اسبابه اه كل سياسيه وفي بقى يعني
هو المشكله في
في المشكله مثل هذه الاحكام او هذه
القضايا القاضي الفرد المتطلع
يخاطب الراي لا يخاطب من شيخ الازهر و
انهم متورطون في شعار في الكلام لم يثبت
قضائيا
والازهر هو المناره التي تحدثوا بالوسطيه
ليس لنا مشكله في هذا انما اقحام هذه
الامور السياسيه في حكم قضائي هو الذي
يشير او يعني يرشح ان المساله المساله
مساله الشعبه السياسيه
دكتور هاشم ربيع عمر هاشم عفوا اه بالنسبه
لكم انتم صدور هذا الحكم بحضر التنظيم
جماعه الاخوان المسلمين في الوقت الذي
نسمع عن جهود للمصالحه الوطنيه عن مبادرات
وغير ذلك عن مساله احتواء هذه الجماعه في
العمل السياسي وليس اقصائها اين وصلت او
اه اه يعني وضعت هذه الاحكام او هذا الحكم
اين وضع كل هذه الجهود وهذا الكلام السابق
عن مستقبل العمل السياسي للجماعه اه بدايه
ال ال هذه القضيه مرفوعه 16 فبراير 2012
يعني بعد انتخابات مجلس الشعب مباشر لكن
التوقيت له دلاله والتوقيت
يعني في طبعا ما محدد القضاء والقضاء
الدعوه المرفوعه وهكذا صدر واه بالتاكيد
سوف يؤثر على المناخ المصالحه يعني من
يقول انه
بالتاكيد سوف على الاقل حتى من قبيل واضحه
كسيف مسلط على رقبه الجماعه ان هناك حكم
القضاء يا ما طبيعه هذا الحكم وما قاله ال
ال ال ال استاذ منتصر اه وما قاله اخرين
في التقييم والحكم لكن سوف يظل سيفا مسلطا
هو بقي الاحكام لانه ربما تكون احكام في
الطريق اخرى اه يوم 12 فبراير انه في
القضايا
القادم ربما هناك احكام مشابها هذه
الاحكام اذا كانت صدرت سوف تصدر بشكل
مشابه اه وهي ستنظر من احكام محكمه القضاء
المحكمه ال اقوى بكثير فربما تكون
بالتاكيد سيفا مسلطا على مساله ال ال
المصالحه لكن
دعني اقول لك ان جماعه الاخوان المسلمين
بها حوالي يمكن سبعمائه الف
منظمه
هذا هذا الكم من العضويه لا يمكن ان هؤلاء
لا يعني يمكن ان تقوم به لكن في نفس الوقت
يجب ان ننظر من جانب اخر ان سبعمائه الف
اه هم اه لا يشكلون الا واحد في المائه
اليوم الوطنيه بغض النظر عن كان كان انجلس
ومائه الف او مليون او خمسه مليون لكن هذه
الجماعه لها وجود في الحياه السياسيه ولها
وجود في النشاط الاجتماعي ولها تاريخ
تقدمه في المجتمع هل يعني يكون مقبولا كما
تقول ان تستخدم
ان تستخدم اسيك لمسح كل هذا التاريخ لمثل
هذا الوجود لما تكون لهذه القاعده الشعبيه
اه هذا الحكم ال
لم يكن هو الذي مسح وكشف المسح يعني
انجازات امنهم الذي الكشف هذا المساء
المسح حدث منذ اكثر من سنه عندما كشفت او
حدث نوع من خلال اه اه جماعه تكون الم
وسياسات هذه الجماعه من خلال ممارسه عام
كامل في الحكم استطاعت من خلاله امتحان
تتحكم في مفاصل الدوله من خلال تحكيم شعار
المغالبه وليس المشاركه او عدم احداث اي
توافق بين
الانواع التوافق الوطني اه داخل المجتمع
كل هذه الامور انا اتصور او هذا الميراث
الكبير الذي خلفته ال ال الجماعه في الحكم
في هذه الفتره القتل ان العالم من من اه
من من عمر مصر انا اتصور انها هي التي ادت
الى ذلك وهي التي لم تجعل هذا الامر الا
اه كشف يعني هذا هذا عكس المنطقه السياسي
الديمقراطي الذي يقول بتداول السلطه ان
اخطا هذا فالشعب هو الذي سيعاقبه بس عبر
صناديق الاقتراع
ولا يمكن ان يقبل احد
الحكم اليوم هو بمثابه كما قال بعضهم
تمزيق ل شهاده الوفاه لشخص ما زال حيا
ومازال
ان لا اعباء كثير من الحكم ولا ينبغي انها
يعني اولا زي ما نقول استانف هذا الحكم
الابتدائي او حكم جزءا لكن الاهم عبد
الناصر
المطرقه الحديديه التي حاول بها ان يقضي
على الاخوه المسلمين وان يقيهم وان يستاصل
شافتهم
بالبوليس بالسجن الحربي الكلاب البوليسيه
بحمد الله كانوا حديثي الوجود وكانوا حديث
اه كان فيه بردو ائمه وعلماء الدين
ومفكرين وسياسه وسياسيون بيقولوا الاخوه
الاعداء الشعب
نحن امه لا تقرا يقرا اللي كان المنشور
يروح الكتاب في الصحف
الاخوان اعداء الشعب الاخوان الشياطين اه
وهكذا
التاريخ بيتكرر
اخوان انتو عبد الناصر غير غيبه الموت لكن
الاخوه نعود اكثر قوه اكثر
اه اه نفس المطرقه هذه استعملها حسني
مبارك
ثلاثين سنه يعني خلينا نتكلم في هذا بهذا
بهذا الشكل مش معقول المحكمه
خمسه وثمانين سنه
اه احنا بنتكلم عن فيك القبول الاخر يا
اللي كنت واشتبكوا انه فيه اقصاء ليكون ان
تكرر نفس الحكايه انا مش ان تتعامل مع
الحكم
انه نهايه الموضوع لا اطلاقا الاخوان
المسلمين وهم جماعه محظوره فى عهد حسنى
مبارك كان
في البرلمان يعني وهم جماعه محظوره الاخوه
الاخوان المسلمين وهي دون التحرك تحت
مطرقه السلطه يعني المساله ليش يعني
حيث كان ال الاستاذ عمر هاشم هنا يعني كان
هناك ترحيب يعني لافت من بعض من قاده جبهه
القياده الجماعيه وطنيه تغيير وحركه تمرد
الصادر اليوم يعني اليس من المستغرب ان
اناس يدعون التحضر
اناس يدعون ا ال ال ال ال يعني التشبع
ثقافه الديمقراطيه
وعانوا في وقت الاوقات من الاقصاء في عهد
سابقه الان هم اه اه يعني يصرون على منطق
الاقصاء والاستئصال لمجرد خصومه سياسيه لا
هناك فرق بين القوى السياسيه ال التي
تتالف من احزاب سياسيه اه دخلت معترك
الحياه السياسيه من المنطلقات الطبيعي وهو
المنطلق المدني المنطلق الطبيعي لقيام
احزاب سياسيه او المطلق المدني وانتحار
هذه القوه بعد ان اه اه تنشا وبعد ان
تتاسس ويتحول الى احزاب سياسيه ذات طابع
ديني هي قبله شرط او احد الشروط الاساسيه
اللعبه السياسيه وهو العمل المدني واجبها
تنحرف وتتجه الى ادخال الدين في السياسه
والسياسه في الدين بشكل ملتبس الالمانيه
ادى ما زال موجود في الحياه السياسيه انت
تابعت انتخابات المانيه في ال يعني بالامس
المسيحيه داخل وكذا والى اخره هذه الدول
الليبراليه
مباراه الذكرى في اه اسماء الاحزاب
تطبيق الشريعه بالحرف بشكل حرفي استاذ الى
ذلك
الدين خاصه في المجتمعات الناميه بتاعت
الحياه السياسيه لانه يفسد المنافسه
المنافسه عندما تقول ان برنامجه علماني
وانا برنامج الاشتراكي وهذا
ويصبح الاخر يقول لك لا الحمد لله عليك ان
المنافسه مع رفع شعارات دينيه هذه وجهه
نظر بالتاكيد كنت اريد ان اشرك هنا معنا
ضيفنا من لندن ابراهيم ولكن سناخذ الان
فاصل نناقشها بعده تداعيات قرار حضروا
جماعه الفصل الاول
اسمح لي وتواصل
قوات اه يعني ناقش تداعيات قرار حضر تنظيم
الاخوه المسلمين في ضوء الخبره اعضائه
التاريخيه في العمل في ظل التقييد
القانوني والا نعود اليكم بعد الفاصل
[موسيقى]
انا بكم من جديد في هذه الحلقه التي تناقش
ابعاد قرار احدى المحاكم المصريه بحظر
انشطه تنظيم الاخوان المسلمين
اه لعل ضيفنا من لندن ابراهيم منير عضو
مكتب الارشاد في جماعه الاخوان المسلمين
جاهز معنا من لندن الاستاذ ابراهيم منير
مرحبا بك كيف
ستواجهون الواقع الذي سيترتب عن هذا الحكم
القضائي ان كان له اه اه ما سيطره طبعا
يعني استطاع
شارع بسيطه التعبير المدني حكما مدني امام
الحكم الديني او يعني ايضا التعبير الذي
يحاول ان يغطي الحكم العسكري الموجود الان
وكان الاسلام السياسي او ال تلك انسان من
مدينه على العمل الاسلام
يقال ان هذا الحكم بدل ان هذا ليس مدني
وحكم كان يعني هذا الخط
منتظرين اما كيف
خمسين هذا الحكم ال العجيب اه والان في
مسارات قليله او تترك للاستاذ
الالم تطوير الذي يريد ان يدافع عن فكره
الاستراليه وفكره حقوق الناس
ليست المره الاولى التي يحاول العسكر
الملاحظه ايضا ولعلها مش لكل الله كل حل
لجماعه الخامس دائما
او في حكم عسكريه عن طريق ابدا على
الاطلاق طوال التاريخ الماضي على
الحب المدني اربعه واربعين مائه وخمسين
وخمسه وستين وخمسه وتسعين قبل
عن طريق محاكم استثنائيه
الكلام الان عندما موجوده موجوده بدي
اشتراكها بافراد الجامعه ولا يستطيع ان
استاذ ان نقطع على الاقل من كل منا في
الخامس من الجماعه لها اه اه في هذا البلد
ولا وجود مع الناس وتواصل مع الناس
التواصل المجتمعي تواصل المعيشي تواصل
سياسي ثقافي هذا كان يحدث النقابات ال اه
المعززه وفي غيره عندما تكون هناك حريه
حريه الانتخابات انما ياتي فصيل معين
كما دعا ويقول العالقه محظوره وان هذا
العمل المخالف القضيه الدستور النص
ان الاسلام الوزاره التشريع وان
كيف حتى بالنص الفلسطينيه التي يحاول
القفز عليها من حق اي فصيل سياسي ان يقيم
اي اه اي عمل سياسي او اي فصيل
يعمل سياسي على
الاجيال السماويه هذا ال
حياته بحسب شريعه النظريه وكلها هذا خاصه
بالاحوال الشخصيه كما يقال
ولو ان ما كان يقال الخلق بالاشتراك
وغير اخلاقيه الشرقيه والمركزيه عندما كان
يريد ان يصل سلوك الناس
الشخصيه او تاخذ في دين امر
بالنسبه قيادات الجماعه الان اما انها
معتقله او انها مطارده هل هل ربما هناك اه
اه تفكير داخل اه اه الجماعه
لاظهار قياده جديده ل ربما تكون شابه
بعدما اتهمه اه اه اه المدير السابق الجيل
القيادي بانه اخفق في اداره المرحله اه اه
سواء الحاليه والسابقه
اتجاه الذي يقول ان الجيل هذه الاتهامات
هذا الجيل
هذه الاتهامات متوجهه الى الى الى قياده
ال الاخوان
اللي
تاتي هذه الت من داخل الصف
تدخل الشك ما
تحقق في هذا الكلام وان كان وغيرها ان
الهدف من يحاول يعني انها
محاوله لتشويه والتي
سيارات جماعه الفلسطينيين هناك اخطاء
لا يمكن ان يغطي البشر
كما انها اي الاخطاء هذه
من القطع والخطيئه انما هذه الاخطاء
البشريه التي تاتي فيها
العمل العادي السياسي العادي او المجتمع
العاديه او الشخص العادي هذا القطاع ولكن
ولكن الحكمه تعلم اه او الاستفاده من دروس
التي
تتخذ من الاخطاء يعني في في في تركيا مثلا
تجربه اه اربكان للحزب رفاه حينما من حزبه
واسس حزب اخر وثاني وثالث ثم خرجت الاخير
حزب الحريه والحزب العداله والتنميه عفوا
وظهرت قيادات جديده كان لها وجودك اردوجان
وعبد الله غول مثلا
كان يحكمها كمان تترك غير تركيه حتى لا
تسمح
يحكم العسكري الذي الان يحاكمون الان
انقلاب 1908 الذي قاله كان عن
يحاكمون الجنايات
قاله الاستاذ وفي
حال السياسي كان غير سياسيه هذا امر كلما
الان الموضوع موجوده الان في حاله المصريه
ان القيادات مختطفه ان القيادات لم يسمع
منها اي شيء ووجه ولا
نعرف الهدف الصحيحه اوقات اه انما الان ال
الشباب على مين الشباب الذين كانوا يتصلون
بالسياده وعشرين ما والقياده التي
يعني بعضهم بعض ال الان الموجود اذا
[موسيقى]
اه يعني اي اي حال الجماعه نعتذر حزب
القانون غير شرعي وتعمل جماعه قواعدنا
شكرا استاذ ابراهيم
نكتفي بهذا القدر اه شكرا لك ابراهيم منير
عضو مكتب الارشاد في جماعه الاخوان
المسلمين لندن حتى معضله بين كما هناك
تقريبا حوالي دقيقتين
الان سؤال يعني حينما حينما اه يعني تحضر
جماعه لها وجود لها برنامج لها مرجعيه في
هذه من العمل في في في في في النور الا
ربما هذا بعض الشباب او جماعات سياسيه
اخرى اسلاميه للعمل في الظلام او العمل
بشكل شرعي هذا السؤال السؤال
الحكمه يفتح الباب امام دعم اه ال التقاتل
او ال ال الانقسام المجتمعين الموسم يعني
انا افهم ان دور الدوله ان تدعم الكيانات
والتكوين السياسيه العمل في نوع من واجب
الدوله انها تقنع
المتطرفين او المتشددين الذين لقوا لنا
لكن هذا الحكم مشكلته بانه يدعم الذين
يخاصمون فكره الديمقراطيه لكن ايضا السؤال
من جهه اخرى ال يستطيع هذا ان يؤثر على
المؤمنين بضروره التغيير بالعمليه
الديمقراطيه السياسيه انا اقول لك لانه
احنا احنا مين التيار الاسلامي استفاد في
التسعينات كانوا يدفعوننا دفعا الى العنف
يدفعنا دفعا الى العنف علشان
يرتكب العنف وبالتالي يبرر بضربنا الكلام
ده بيحصل من ساعه عزل الرئيس مرسي في
محاولات لدفع الضرر يكون لا القصد منها
انه انه انه انه شباب يخطئ وان الشباب
يمارس العنف لغير دلوقتي من يشوش في هذا
وانا استطيع ان اقول لكن لكن الاشكاليه
التي يطلع هذا الحكم انه يسمح بميلاد
صناعه التطرف
دكتور عمر هاشم تعليقا
منتصر النوع يؤدي العمل السري لكن وزير
على اه ان سمح لي واقول متى توقف الاخوان
على العمل السري هو جزء منهم منذ نشاتهم
باختلاف الدرجه يعني الاختلاف الدرجه هذه
واحده الامر الثاني ما ذكره الاستاذ
الدكتور ابراهيم اه اه هو بالتاكيد
ندخل المسلمين في رفض النقد الذاتي على
الاقل العالمي هذا امر الامر الثالث ما ما
هو مطروح حاليا من حكم وزير الاحكام
القادمه اذا كان في نفس الاتجاه بالتاكيد
على الانتخابات القادمه بشكل ايجابي
ايجابي على التيار السلفي باعتباره هو
التيار الديني الوحيد المتواجد على الساحه
المصريه شكرا لك دكتور عمر هاشم ربيع
الخبير في مركز الاهرام للدراسات السياسيه
والاستراتيجيه نشكر ال استاذ منتصر الزيات
رئيس اللجنه القوميه الدفاع عن سجناء
الراي بهذا تنتهي مشاهدينا الكرام هذه
الحلقه من برنامج من خبراء في حلقه اخرى
شكرا لكم والسلام عليكم ورحمه الله
وبركاته
ام
[موسيقى]